[Music]
so Katie is calling this her witness
house named after her new album of
course and already there have been lots
of revelations here are four things we
never knew about Katy Perry like I have
a germ thing too
so she's a germaphobe Katy's been super
candid about everything else
revelation number two how she might have
gotten over some former flames to take
selfies of myself when I was crying when
I was upset in a relationship to show me
that like it wasn't all a better roses
you say you want people to speak your
language what is your language and what
does that mean I love speaking through
music and that's the way that I speak to
people is through my music and even when
like I get to date someone we talk
through songs it's not alcohol it's I
will do revelation number three he knows
her limits I am um really sensitive all
substance or so sensitive that my
hangovers are literally like three days
I can't get out of bed it's a delicate
dance so the song dancing the devil is
about my dance with alcohol but now I
don't feel like I have to be that way
I'm very proud of Who I am
Katy's beloved pump nugget is all over
the house with her showing us her
maternal side so here's revelation
number four I'd love to be a mom soon
definitely I just mean I just would like
to find my partner we do know Katy's big
on yoga she did that with pal Jesse
Tyler Ferguson today et is the first
show inside the Big Brother style house
we wanted to know what does Julie Chen
think about it I was tickled pink I was
like really
I'll watch and I've been watching I
invite her to come and try this at the
Big Brother house because all of our
camera operators are behind glass and
you can really feel free if she just
stays true to who she is she'll be fine
but easier said than done with a big
camera line
now Katy will be live on YouTube all
weekend long and she's gonna be joined
by some of her famous friends Jesse
Tyler Ferguson is gonna come by to do a
little yoga si is gonna come hang out
and she's gonna cook with Gordon Ramsay
[Music]
you